c'est une vidéo qui est un peu
particulière aujourd'hui parce que je
viens vous parler de mon job de youtube
heures la face cachée de mon métier de
youtube heures l'idée ici c'est j'irai
pas de casser un peu les préjugés mais
de vous expliquer en réalité comment ça
se passe le concret le quotidien comment
je vais travailler avec des marques
comment je vais dealé avec des marques
sont les sources de revenus sur youtube
en tout cas dans la partie tech dans mon
job à moi ici vous expliquer toutes les
réalités tout ce que vous voyez pas en
fait c'est vrai qu'ici est toujours un
peu j'en sais rien moi ce qu'on voit au
travers des vidéos et bien c'est à côté
sympa c'est un côté ludique mon jab et
hyper sympa il est génial mais il ya un
côté réglementaire il ya un côté
juridique il faut monter une société il
ya plein de déclarations de tous les
côtés à faire à ma fille est bien côté
un peu contraignant alors je vais vous
montrer ça pour que vous voyez en
réalité comment ça se passe lorsque on
décide de faire un job comme celui là et
qu'on a la chance que j'ai vraiment un
champ cegerco n'est vraiment la chance à
400% armes ennemis depuis 60 ans nous
voulait plus l'infini pour cent la
chance que j'ai de pouvoir faire ça de
pouvoir vivre de ma passion de pouvoir
le partager avec vous c'est vraiment une
vidéo un peu différente je la fais aussi
pour toutes les personnes qui commencent
sur youtube et qui n'hésite bien comment
est ce qu'il faut faire par quel bout il
faut le prendre qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire quels sont les déclarations enfer
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas que j'oublie
comment travailler avec une marque
comment collaborer avec une marque est
ce qu'il vaut pas de ne pas savoir
qu'est ce qu'il faut je pense que je
fasse pas et c'est normal quand on sait
pas on se pose des questions et moi je
me suis posée des tonnes croyez moi donc
la journée ça fait tu commençais ma
chaîne youtube fin 2016 on est
aujourd'hui je trouve cette vidéo en
2022 quelques petites années que je fais
ça puis j'ai appris plein de choses trop
je vais essayer de le partager avec vous
ma rallié tout ce que tu as j'ai pris
des notes parce que j'ai vraiment pas
envie d'oublier des choses je veux aussi
vous parler d'organisation de temps de
travail comment ça se passe comment je
gère mes journées comment est-ce que
j'organise mon temps parce que je publie
vachement donc il faut vachement réalisé
et puis comment on fait pour papeete des
plombs parce que même si ce job il est
extraordinaire même si c'est une chance
incroyable et bien avec une charge de
travail comme ça et quand on est tout
seul quand on est indépendant et que ben
on dépend que d'eux soit en fait il ya
des fois c'est un peu fourre-tout c'est
rock'n'roll on voit là donc c'est ça
fait un très très grand programme ça se
faire une vidéo un peu denses mais je
pense que c'est intéressant de la faire
[Musique]
en fait j'ai pas forcément très envie de
faire cette vidéo et puis j'ai fait une
faq ya pas longtemps et j'ai mon pote
fred qui m'a dit tiens il a posé la
question préambule de la faq parce que
je vous avais demandé sur instagram et
bien qu est ce que vous n'avez comme
boxe que je vous dise quelle réponse
vous voudriez avoir été vos questions
sur tout est frais de la libye maintient
est ce que tu peux nous parler un peu de
la partie business savoir comment ça se
passe tout ça tout ça tout ça quoi ok je
me suis dit ça c'est vachement
intéressant parce qu'on fait j'en ai
jamais parlé et je sais pas s'il y en a
qui ont déjà parlé de ça comme ça sur
you tube et je trouve ça intéressant de
pouvoir effectivement renseigner avant
ceux qui regardent vous qui n'avez pas à
vocation qui n'avait pas prévu de monter
une chaîne youtube mais il ya tellement
de gens qui ont envie de monter une
chaîne youtube ou pour monter une chaîne
youtube et qui savent pas réellement ce
qu'il faut faire je trouve ça cool et
bien de pouvoir voilà vous donner tous
et avant cela la première chose à faire
ça peut paraître un peu con mais je
tiens à l'idée la première chose la plus
importante pour moi c'est la passion on
va pas commencer à faire une chaîne
youtube si on n'a pas de passion on va
pas commencer à se dire matin je prends
une caméra car j'aime filmer si on n'a
pas de passion c'est impossible s'il ya
quelqu'un est idiot qui jette une caméra
et je vais faire youtuber parce que il
ya du pognon offert il se plante
complètement à 400 % pensent que c'est
pas moi on est là pour transmettre des
choses moi je ne sais pas comment vous
le ressentez mais je me dis que si vous
êtes aujourd'hui plus de 500 milles à me
suivre sur youtube c'est peut-être que
ben vous voyez que je suis animé par
quelque chose qui a une passion que j'ai
envie que je suis heureux je vous
emmerde je pense pas vraiment détient
d'avoir gardé un trou de kindai et on le
partage donc cette patiente c'est le fil
conducteur est pour moi ce que je fais
aujourd'hui alors je dis métier parce
que janvier puis qu'il ya toute une
structure et que voilà mais c'est la
passion sans ça y'a rien donc cette
passion elle est là elle est intacte et
c'est vraiment le fil conducteur et
c'est le moteur donc la première chose à
savoir c'est la passion parce que sans
passion vous n'allez pas tenir des
heures à passer des heures à du montage
des heures à chercher des sujets des
heures à tourner des heures à structurer
bref ça c'est pas possible donc la
première chose c'est la passion ça c'est
pas le truc le plus important et je
voulais voir avec vous et puis il ya le
deuxième point on va commencer à rentrer
dedans ça c'est un sujet un peu plus
mais il faut y aller ça coûte un peu
juridique parce que quand on commence à
voir une chaîne youtube qui commence à
marcher qu'on commence à voir quelques
abonnés et qu'on se rend compte
maintient que ça commence à générer un
peu de revenus il sait comment ça se
passait un peu quelque chose il faut
commencer à structurer à la roma
structurelles je vous ai pris un papier
j'ai pris des airs stabilo j'ai pas de
marqueur noir désolé j'ai pas que ça
vous ira ne sais pas d'ailleurs ce qui
sera le mieux pour lire si c'est moi le
rouge ou si c'est le verre je regarde on
va tenter le le maire pour commencer la
première chose à faire quand j'ai
commencé à faire mon activité je faisais
autre chose et j'étais en auto
entrepreneurs dont j'avais déjà la
structure qui me permettait bien de
pouvoir facturer est d'abord un statut
c'est hyper important parce que si on
commence à faire l'objet je vous dis
qu'on commence à générer un peu d'argent
il faut vous protéger il faut avoir un
statut que vous ayez un job à côté que
vous ayez pas job que vous soyez
demandeur d'emploi fait le premier
statut et le premier statut c'est
vachement bien en france je pense que
dans d'autres pays on peut le faire je
pression en belgique 6e en suisse ou
dans tel pays est ce que vous êtes et ce
que vous pouvez le faire ça en tout cas
en france nous on a le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur là je ne sais plus
écrire et ce statut là il est vachement
bien parce que d'une il vous permet
effectivement d'avoir beaucoup de
flexibilité vous permet de facturer je
crois qu'on charge vous avez vous payé
25 % de charge avec un versement
libératoire de l'impôt donc c'est quand
même vachement intéressant et ça vous
permet d'avoir géré une première
structure pour pouvoir travailler donc
là c'était le début après j'ai été voir
un comptable et le comptable m'a dit
monsieur granet c'est bon gros falloir
commencer à structurer différemment
parce qu'il ya des choses qui prennent
forme et auto entrepreneurs c'est bien
mais c'est pas du tout protecteur ça
vous permet d'avoir effectivement une
structure mais ça vous protège pas ou si
vous avez moins de problèmes eh bien
vous êtes entreprises il vous pouvoir
des problèmes donc on s'est dit il aura
faire différemment on va créer ce qu'on
appelle une eurl
voilà le u r elle le url en fait on va
pas faire un truc droit des entreprises
mais le url c'est une sarl
unipersonnelle à dire que c'est une
société à responsabilité limitée
unipersonnelles vous êtes la seule
personne dedans là on peut avoir de les
employer 6 et ça mais vous êtes la seule
personne au capital vous êtes la seule
personne qui a dans ce cas cette boîte
alors après il ya une possibilité une
structure qui existe c'est la sasu on
peut venir également créé après faut
voir vous comment est ce que vous
prévoyez de faire les choses ça ça
découle de la sas qui est la société par
actions simplifiée quelle est la
différence avec le statut d'auto
entrepreneur et ben c'est qu'en fait
auto entrepreneurs l'entreprise si vous
dans tous les cas ça sera moi qu'on
verra les caméras avec si vous
entreprises donc si on vient chercher
quelqu'un pour un problème bien
l'entreprise c'est vous qu'on dise que
là il ya une interface c'est
l'entreprise qu'on vient voir
l'entreprise est une personne morale qui
est une personne différente de vous dont
vous êtes viré protéger derrière
l'entreprise ça c'est vachement
important et surtout qui veut vraiment
vraiment vraiment important a fait en
fait votre entreprise c'est une boîte à
outils qui vous permettra de gérer votre
activité le plus simplement possible
alors après effectivement on peut venir
nous chercher derrière vous s'il ya un
problème de gestion si vous faites
n'importe quoi avec les dents la société
là c'est vous en tant que gérant vous
êtes le genre de notre société on peut
venir vous chercher mais sinon vous êtes
quand même vachement protégées ça c'est
cool donc là c'est la première chose
c'est venir structure ok je pose un
cadre et on se protège et après et on va
commencer à rentrer un peu dans le dur à
avoir placé pour monter une société et
ben qu'est ce qu'il vous faut mais il
vous faut des statuts pour votre société
des statuts en temps on trouve des
modèles sur internet autant je vous
déconseille réellement venir les prendre
pour faire vos statuts qu'est ce qu'il
vous faut et des rivaux faut un avocat
et un avocat forcément ça coûte de
l'argent mais au moins vous poser les
choses sereinement et vous pouvez
commencer à travailler correctement et
puis qu'est ce qui se passe autour d une
boîte comme ça il faut la piloter alors
il ya plein de choses à voir ici il
bondit c'est un petit peu complexe mais
non en fait si vous êtes en eurl vous
vos allées des déclarations sociales que
vous devez déclarer et payer ça se passe
du côté du rsi et si vous êtes en cesu
vous est assignée salariés quelque chose
près et là vous dépendez de l'urssaf
voilà les sympathiques tout ça mais pour
faire ces déclarations et pour le payer
parce que je vous conseille première
chose à faire parce que je suis pas
comptable est bien c'est de prendre un
comptable donc il vous faut aujourd'hui
deux intervenants lorsque vous venez
créer une structure comme celle là la
première c'est un avocat pour créer les
statuts et tous les ans il vat à venir
pour le bilan de votre société et pour
l'assemblée générale et puis votre
comptable qui va être là pour faire
toutes les déclarations vous avez à
faire mais qu'il le fera bien parce que
c'est son job c'est pas le truc ça c'est
un truc est vachement cool parce que
youtube organise régulièrement et il le
faisait avant le tribun il continue à le
faire quand nous on continue ils vont
peut-être le reprendre et bien c'est des
ateliers ou des créateurs expérimentés
viennent parler à des créateurs plutôt
débutants et qui ont besoin de savoir
des choses et on avait fait un atelier
qui était vachement cool autour du
bien-être il ya des chars de la chaîne
face bout de cuisine qui est intervenu
et qui avait dit la première chose à
faire lorsque vous créez une chaîne
youtube et que ça commence à fonctionner
mais évidemment c'est prendre un
comptable c'est la première chose à
faire comme ça - vous êtes dans les
règles il n'y a pas de souci la deuxième
chose à faire derrière c'est prendre un
monteur mais ça on en a parlé un petit
peu plus tard alors une fois que vous
avez créé votre boîte que vous avez
votre avocat pour vos statuts vous avez
votre comptable pour vos déclarations et
bien là on peut commencer à s'amuser à
savoir que vol comparé il va faire quoi
il va faire aussi toutes les
déclarations de tva mais ouais parce que
vous allez vous facturer pour commencer
à rentrer de l'argent il faut forcément
payer de la tva vous n'encaissez vous
devez adapter faut que ce soit fait
correctement ça c'est un job du
comptable d'où l'importance d'avoir un
contact plus plus plus plus plus vous
avez ensuite toutes vos déclarations
dies liesse et l'impôt sur les sociétés
c'est pas différent de n'importe quelle
société 1 chaque société doit
fonctionner comme ça mais là comme on
est dans un métier effectivement ou
d'image commence un job passion c'est
bien d'avoir cette vision comment
structurer sa boîte et qu'est ce qu'on
doit payer pour par entreprise alors
votre comptable il va vous faire
également et bien votre bilan comptable
donc comme ça hop il vous fera le bilan
à la fin de l'année voilà ce que vous
avez gagné voilà ce qui va ce qui va pas
essayer ça tandis que l'avocat lui
rédigé ensuite je dirais pas le bilan
mais venir rédigé l'assemblée générale
déposer votre bilan auprès du greffe du
tribunal de commerce batt pas toutes ces
démarches administratives qui sont super
importante que je vous conseille de
faire faire par des professionnels ça il
ya un autre truc qu'il faut faire et
j'ai l'impression qu'il a pas beaucoup
de créateurs qu'ils le savent c'est ce
qu'on va venir a appelé ici vais le
faire tous les mois c'est ce qu'on
appellera une ds alors la ds c'est quoi
la ds la déclaration européenne de
services et une déclaration vous allez
faire de tout ce que vous avez gagné sur
le mois en cours et vous la faites
auprès des douanes françaises alors
rassurez vous ça c'est pas un truc que
vous allez payer mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que si vous commencez à
générer de l'argent par des revenus
d'affiliation que vous commencez à
toucher de l'argent par google et qu'est
ce qui se passe dans notre ami google et
google en europe eh bien il est basé en
irlande donc vous avez des revenus qui
viennent d'un pays européen et donc on
doit faire une déclaration européenne de
services pour venir ventilé ce qui sort
de l'irlande si l'époque de google et
qui rendent chez vous et puis par
exemple si vous faites de la filiation
avec amazon qui aujourd'hui un
incontournable
amazon ils sont au luxembourg donc c'est
la même chose drop déclaration
européenne de services donc vous devez
vous inscrire sur le site pro douanes et
vous faites votre déclaration tous les
mois ce pas très compliqué vous devez
rentrer le numéro de tva de l'entreprise
vouloir trop richesse de son souk un
problème et vous devez déclarer le
montant que vous avez encaissé ça c'est
obligatoire sans quoi vous aurez des
problèmes ça c'est le premier point il
faut le faire tous les mois alors soit
vous prenez un comptable qui va tout
gérer de a z qui va faire beau
facturation vos relances mais ça va vous
coûter une blinde et je pense pas que
sur la bonne chose à faire je pense que
c'est à vous de gérer le courant est à
vous de gérer et je dirai tout ce qui va
être suivi de vos finances ça veut dire
vos factures vous devez et dicter vos
propres factures vous devez éditer vos
propres de vie vous devez relancer vos
clients vous devez voir où est ce que
son nez est ce que ça s'est bien passé
est-ce qui vous ont payé mais bon si
vous voulez vous sortir le stade
lavallois qui bouillent ces gens là donc
à toutes ces choses là à venir voire
d'un point de vue structurel trituration
l'activité et puis il ya un autre truc
et je vous en parlais tout à l'heure on
vient se protéger avec sa société il ya
un truc qui est vraiment important et
j'ai l'impression qu'à pas beaucoup de
personnes qui le fait il vous faut ce
qu'on appelle une rcp une assurance
responsabilité civile professionnelle au
même titre que quand vous prenez un
logement une maison essayer ça vous avez
dans votre contrat d'assurance une
responsabilité civile pour vous titre
personnel vous en faut une pour votre
job qui va venir vous protéger en cas de
jeu pas vous prenez vous casser un
matériel ma vous renverser quelqu'un
dans le cadre de votre activité
professionnelle vous créez un tort à
quelqu'un quel qu'il soit votre rcp
aller là pour vous protéger et c'est
vachement important parce que si vous
avez des problèmes ne faisaient pas du
rcp c'est vous directement qu'elle était
embêté et croyez moi que ça vous fera
pas marre et donc finir cpc important il
ya bravo protégé pour une certaine somme
il faut trouver la rcp qui vous
correspond mais il y en a pas trop de
ses 1100 marché a trouvé une seule ça
c'est un truc qui est vraiment vraiment
importante donc j'invite vraiment à
venir vous renseigner là dessus et puis
ensuite qu'est ce qu'il faut faire parce
qu'on est indépendant et ben y'a un truc
est aussi super important et auquel on
pense pas forcément il faut une
prévoyance ré en fait c'est quoi la
prévoyance comme vous êtes votre propre
patron et que vous êtes vous la seule
personne qui va très vite dans la boîte
et bien si demain vous vous cassez les
deux bras et les deux jambes et que vous
êtes hospitalisé pendant je sais pas
combien de temps il n'y a plus rien qui
va entrer et vous n'avez plus la
possibilité de créer du contenu des
publicités créent des vidéos et donc à
un moment où vous pouvez vous retrouver
embêté si vous êtes un chasseur même
hospitalisé une opération est que
pendant trois mois vous êtes alité sans
pouvoir bouger ça peut rapidement une
problématique à se mettre votre activité
en père et donc il vous faut absolument
une prévoyance à prendre auprès de
n'importe quelle compagnie il y en a des
tonnes et très bien donc je vous invite
à aller vous renseigner les voyez ce
qu'on voit ici là est bien c'est qu'on
commence à avoir un peu une idée de ce
qu'il faut faire pour venir se protéger
je vous le dis un comptable avocat c'est
obligatoire et puis ensuite tous les
mois votre déclaration européenne de
services le suivi de vos finances votre
verre cpa prendre votre prévoyance à
prendre c'est super important également
et puis ensuite si comme moi vous avez
déjà eu lieu dans lequel vous travaillez
et bien vous allez prendre un local avec
forcément un loyer avec des assurances
enfin bref tout ce qui va bien avec
payer l'électricité payé le gaz enfin
j'en sais rien a donc payé toutes vos
charges pour donc ça fait quand même pas
mal de choses à faire deux choses à
payer de choses à penser à faire ça peut
paraître un peu l'eau on est déjà très
très loin dans la vidéo c'est une vidéo
qui va durer extrêmement longtemps mais
c'est l'espèce de tuto pour créer sa
chaîne youtube et correctement et puis
ensuite il vous faut forcément même si
l'auto entrepreneur il vous faut un
compte en banque et je crois que c'est
un truc qui est super important aussi
d'avoir un compte en banque un compte en
banque qui va être séparé de votre
compte perso alors si vous êtes en
on essaiera l onu url en cesu c'est
obligatoire mais si vous êtes en auto
entrepreneur vous invite vraiment
revenir le faire pourquoi parce que ce
compte en banque se permet vraiment de
différencier les choses d'avoir de la
visibilité sur notre trésorerie sur
l'argent que vous avez disponible et ne
pas faire n'importe quoi il faut
vraiment bien structuré cette manière là
et je crois que c'est extrêmement
important et puis si en plus après vous
avez des qualités qui grossit grossit
grossit et que vous avez des salariés
bien il faut gérer les plannings il faut
faire faire par votre comptable les
fiches de paye enfin là c'est une
histoire impossible elle a déjà eu lieu
quand même bien bien gros si vous êtes
armé vous êtes tous les bons partenaires
autour de vous qui sont là pour vous
conseiller et ça c'est quand même une
étape on en est quand même beau sur moi
je suis pas ok donc une fois qu'on a
structuré sa boîte qu'on est bon en fait
ces vidéos assez son courant tous les
jours on fait cette vidéo y'a pas de
soucis on a montré ce qu'est ce qu'il
nous faut là maintenant il faut qu'on
parle un petit peu de revenus comment
est-ce qu'on génère des revenus alors
forcément tout va se faire un petit port
parallèle je prends un peu de façon
décousue mais aujourd'hui sur youtube va
y avoir tout cas moi j'en ai quatre
principales sources de revenus alors
l'idée si c'est pas de vous parler
d'argent mais c'est vraiment de vous
montrer de vous alerter vous expliquer
comment sa faute si on va avoir le
premier ça va être la publicité sur
youtube donc la publicité sur youtube
elle se fait au travers d' à 100 dans
lequel il faut que vous soyez inscrits
qui est la régie publicitaire de youtube
qui va vous versez en fait votre votre
argent donc là effectivement on a bien
vu que c'est l'argent qui rendu google
ireland qu'il faut déclarer via la ds la
déclaration européenne de services
auprès de vos douanes tous les mois au
quai ensuite vous allez avoir un si vous
mettez des liens pour des produits que
vous aimez que vous avez envie de
présenter et bien vous allez toucher ce
qu'on appelle des revenus d'affiliation
d'affiliation donc la filiation aussi
c'est super cool parce que vous dites
maintien j'en sais rien moi je fais de
la tête donc j'adore à certains produits
et j'en sais rien moi je me présente un
iphone bien votre iphone si vous
intéresse vous avez un lien dans
description vous cliquez dessus et moi
je touche quoi trois personnes comme ça
3 4% du prix de l'iphone dont classe et
voilà ça c'est de la filiation mais tous
mes boutabout va ça permet de commencer
à payer un peu des choses et puis
ensuite vous allez avoir des vidéos
sponso ça c'est du sponsoring aux plats
en sauce je dirais que c'est aujourd'hui
ce qui fait tourner tous les youtube
heures et tous les gros youtube earth et
les vidéos sponso et elles vont de
séparer en deux parties vous allez avoir
ce qu'on va appeler l'intégration c'est
à dire des vidéos de 60 à 90 secondes
que vous allez faire au début de votre
vidéo ou alors introduire et ensuite le
mettre à la fin et puis sinon vous allez
avoir la vidéo dédiée qui va parler à
100% dans produits qui vous intéressent
la vidéo dédiée avec 2 donc voilà donc
on a ses principales sources après il
peut y avoir d'autres choses qui
arrivent vous allez pouvoir faire de la
nation à droite à gauche j'en sais rien
bref il y à peine ce n'est pas avec mais
ça c'est la base et cette base elle est
super importante parce que ça vous
permet effectivement de voir où vous
allez d'avoir un peu de visibilité mais
il faut faire extrêmement attention
pourquoi parce que lorsque vous allez
travailler alors la filiation c'est
facile c'est un lien puis on n'en parle
plus youtube c'est pareil c'est les pubs
qui s'affiche pas de problème mais là
cette partie la vidéo sponsors faut
faire vachement garde pourquoi parce que
vous avez travaillé avec des marques et
les marques ce qu'elles veulent et bien
c'est que leurs produits soient vendus
mais vous votre intérêt c'est quoi et
bien ses deux conseillers correctement
votre audience et pas de dire n'importe
quoi et pas se travestir pour faire
plaisir aux marques et ça fait vachement
vachement gaffe donc il faut parler avec
les mains ok vous voulez que je parle
d'un produit la première chose à vous
dire c'est un est ce que j'aime ce
produit est ce que j'y crois sans ça on
n'y va pas si vous aimez si vous pensez
qu'un service rendu si vous pensez qu'il
ya un intérêt pour votre audience vous
pouvez y aller sinon on laisse tomber on
n'y va pas c'est vraiment je me sens
extrêmement important on s'est offert
quatre passes cas des marques qui vont
des fins de moins en moins aux lettres
dormir et quelques unes ça arrive encore
qui vise d'intérêt il faut dire çà çà çà
çà çà ok alors non donnez moi la fiche
produit ce qui concerne moins dans la
tête dit moi de quoi va parler votre
produit je vais voir parler et faire ma
review de façon honnête je vais dire ok
il ya ça qui va il ya ça qui va pas et
les marques elles comprennent
aujourd'hui que c'est important de dire
ce qu'il va pas parce que de toute façon
une fois que consommateurs leur acheter
il verra ce qu'il va pas d'occire vous
n'êtes pas vous honnête d'une votre
audience ne vous croira plus jamais
c'est super important et puis deux de la
marque ça desservira pas ce qu'on dira
ok j'ai testé ça ça paraissait bien et
en fait cessé complètement mauvais dont
il faut vraiment et il perd transparence
il a marqué le comprendre il faut
vraiment lui expliquer voilà et c'est
une discussion dans les deux sens une
fois que vous avez fait ça une fois que
tout le monde est d'accord là dessus il
ya un point qui est hyper hyper hyper
hyper hyper important c'est de faire un
contrat un contrat qui va stipulé ce qui
va se passer quand c'est ce que vous
allez publier quelle rémunération vous
allez à voir quels sont les points que
vous allez aborder pour que une fois que
la vidéo est fait et vous l'envoyez à la
marpa ce qu'elle doit à regarder elle a
forcément un droit de regard là-dessus
et c'est normal pas tant pour vous dire
non non je veux pas que tu dis ça et ça
surtout pour dire il n'y a pas d'erreur
il n'y a pas de coquille et on est ok
sur ce qu'on a dit mais dès le départ il
faut s'entendre et on s'entend parce que
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans un
contrat quand tu m'as bien vouloir vous
discuté avec elle vous tombés d'accord
il faut déjà aimé le produit vous tomber
d'accord vous faites un contre alors
souvent c'est elle qui avoue que
proposez vous le réalisez et dans son
cas le truc auquel il faut faire
vachement gaffe alors il ya la rémunère
sur son âme il ya la gestion des droits
souvent des marques pas ton des marques
mais des fois des agences elles vont
vouloir vous dire de la ville vos droits
1 c'est à dire le droit qu'on va
utiliser votre vidéo à des fins
publicitaires qu'on l'utilisé nous pour
faire la promo sur nos réseaux compagnie
ktha sénat il faut discuter avec la
marque lorsque les droits c'est un truc
en plus c'est donc ce serait con de
passer à côté pour tous et votre image
c'est à dire que si une marque décide
demain bien de promouvoir ou une agence
d'utiliser votre vidéo de la pub lien
pas de vote à gauche n'est pas forcément
prévu parce que vous vous dites ok moi
je fais une vidéo mais allez sur ma
chaîne n est pas chez vous donc céder
tous qu'il faut vraiment venir voir
encadré ces histoires devenir aussi se
protéger parce que c'est vachement
important et les to qui sont tous qu'on
met il faut pas oublier que c'est votre
image qui est en jeu donc voilà et une
fois de plus il ya des marques qui
viennent nous voir avec les brief on
écrit des trucs vous dit çà çà çà çà
c'est génial c'est si c'est ça si vous
pensez que c'est parce qu'elle vous dit
pas vraiment vous dit pas il faut
refuser vous dit non je ferai pas cette
colonne jaffré paris c'est pas grave
d'avoir une autre qui arrivera plus tard
alors je peux comprendre quand on débute
on se dit ouais mais ça ne paye mon
boitier moi ça me plaît ouais c'est vrai
mais donc parce qu'il faut vraiment
rester droit c'est important et puis
ensuite y'a un truc qui est super
important lorsque vous faites une vidéos
sponsorisées vous devez le dire ça doit
être honnête c'est écrit donc vous devez
le mentionner au début de votre vidéo à
l'oral par exemple la batterie
aujourd'hui cette vidéo est réalisée en
partenariat avec telle marque merci
at-elle mark ii sponsorisées cette vidéo
vous le dites pas à la fin vous le dites
pas au mieux et vous dit dès le début
c'est super important alors soit vous le
dites directement soit vous venez coché
la petite case sur youtube c'est fou
comment elle s'appelle comment s'écrit
je déclare qu'il ya un classement de
produits ou à la il est couché cette
petite case lorsque vous voulez appeler
votre vidéo salafistes dès le départ
alors si par exemple c'est dans le cadre
d'une intégration et que votre
intégration elle commence à 30 secondes
ou une minute lorsque vous commencez
intégration lorsque c'est une partie où
il ya une rémunération vous dites cette
vidéo est réalisée en partenariat moi je
me fais lorsque je présente des coques
de partenaires de cette vidéo est
réalisée en partenariat avec tel
partenaire et vous le dit et c'est
important est de la même manière dans la
description vous devez marquer cette
vidéo est réalisée en partenariat avec
telma qu'on doit pouvoir l'identifier et
c'est extrêmement important sans quoi
vous allez voir des problèmes avec la
répression c'est quoi sa direction
générale de la répression des fraudes
qui va venir taper à votre porte à vous
dire bonjour montrez-moi toutes vos
factures on va regarder les vidéos et on
va voir si effectivement ces loyers
n'essayez pas de problème et si un
problème bien vous fait allumer nous
fait allumer et 2 franchement par
rapport à votre audience c'est vraiment
vraiment pas terrible parce qu'il faut
toujours être réglo et leur expliquer
c'est ma façon bosser on savait pas dire
quand je fais une vidéo sponso je suis
pas loyal je le suis vraiment à 400%
mais pour autant il faut le dire et puis
c'est normal parce qu'on a nous sur
youtube un business model qui fait qu'
il y a personne qui me plaît je suis pas
journaliste n'a pas une rédaction qui
est là pour me payer pour faire mon
métier donc c'est moi qui me paye donc
un moment il faut bien que génère des
revenus soit il revenu youtube sont
largement suffisants que soient ses
couplets à l'affiliation ça fonctionne
mais des fois ça peut pas être suffisant
pour vous permettre vous ensuite dans
vivre et vous professionnaliser et bien
on passe par la case vidéo spawn chômé
pour autant cette case vidéo sponso doit
faire que vous travaillez de la même
manière lorsque vous faites une vidéo
qui énonce qu on soit une vidéo sponso
la différence est la grosse différence
c'est une fois de plus le discours avec
la marque et le fait que la marque elle
va regarder la vidéo mais vous devez pas
dire n'importe quoi et il faut pas faire
de concessions fois le droit dans ses
bottes toujours sur six statues c'est
super important alors on va ensuite
devenir parler d'un point qui est aussi
un peu primordial ne sont pas dire un
peu ou carrément primordial c'est votre
organisation de votants de travail et
c'est vrai que allez on se dit et quand
je regarde les vidéos youtube parce que
je regarde moi aussi je suis un grand
consommateur de vidéos youtube c'est
génial et on se rend pas compte derrière
du temps de travail qui a et c'est un
truc de fou alors bien évidemment et je
vous le dis on fait ça parce qu'on est
passionné si on n'est pas passionné on
peut pas tenir dans la durée c'est pas
possible et puis on le sent je me dis la
passion ça se transmet s'il n'y a pas de
passion aime se transmet et rennes
marche à la bonne vôtre non c'est super
important moi aujourd'hui sans la chaîne
youtube la vidéo sur tout de suite parce
que j'ai un numéro est en fait celle que
j'ai tout de suite c'est la 1198 8e
vidéo que je tourne autant vous dire
j'en ai fait un paquet alors detroit il
m'arrivait de commencer des vidéos et
puis bien non je maintenant j'ai pas
trop envie tu crois pas donc la publie
pas mais mille 198e vidéo j'ai
énormément de vidéos qui sont publiées
sur ma chaîne youtube est en fait moi
j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos sur ma
chaîne fin 2016 et a vraiment commencé à
bosser à fond dessus début 2018 et
aujourd'hui je trouve cette vidéo on est
en 2022 non voyez il ya en fait quatre
ans et pendant quatre ans
1198 vidéo alors qu'est ce que j'ai fait
je travaillais comme un bourrin c'est à
dire que moi je suis quelqu'un de
passionné c'est ma façon de faire c'est
à dire que je suis un boulimique de
travail et quand j'aime quelque chose je
suis à 400% dessus et je fais que ça que
ça que ça que ça que ça donc je suis un
pur à dire que j'entends sauvage dans
mon boulot mais c'est parce que j'aime
ça donc je bosse je bosse je bosse je
bosse je bosse je produis j'ai tellement
envie de vous montrer de quoi j'étais
tellement envie de partager de choses
que je fais que ça et en fait ce qui
fait que et c'est super important à voir
il faut faire gaffe alors je vous parle
de mon cas à moi mais pour vous voyez
vous ce que vous pouvez faire et faire
attention et vous allez voir pourquoi
parce que en gros deux demies 18 jusqu'à
début 2000 20 avec le co vide j'ai
publié une vidéo par jour et ça je vous
parle de 7 jours sur 7 j'écrivais je
tournais et je montais du lundi au
dimanche inclus donc ça fait une très
grosse quantité de vidéos mais ça fait
aussi une très grosse charge de travail
ça fait aussi beaucoup de fatigue ça
fait aussi des grosses concessions qu'on
va devoir faire par rapport à sa vie
familiale par rapport à sa vie avec ses
amis donc mais bon voilà ça correspond à
moi à ma façon de fonctionner c'est pas
dit que c'est ça qu'il faut faire je
pense pas mais moi je suis un boulimique
de travail voilà donc il faut faire
gaffe donc ce qui est super importante
c'est de venir structure et comment on
travaille alors il ya des outils pour
venir bien géré ça moi tout le début
j'utilisais un outil qui s'appelle très
lo qui est cool qui vous permet
effectivement de la gestion de bases de
données voilà les sujets que j'ai envie
de faire dans les studios que j'ai fait
voilà ce que j'avais publié voilà ce que
j'ai publié mais très lo c'est pas mal
mais c'est pas suffisant et je suis
passé sur un autre outil que je trouve
beaucoup plus performant qui s'appelle
no fun qui est gratuit si vous êtes tout
seul à l'utiliser et puis c'est pas très
cher ce qui vous attend l'équipe donc
très lo c'est bien mais bon on va passer
sur nos champs et nos chaînes c'est ouf
je peux j'avais tellement plus de choses
c'est pas bien c'est de la gestion de
bases de données enfin bref c'est une
espèce de faux que vous allez voir mais
là dessus je veux bien noté mes idées de
vidéos les vidéos qui sont en cours les
vidéos où j'ai tourné ou est-ce que j'en
suis je peux venir libre atteint lorsque
j'ai un partenariat je peux venir le lit
enfin moi peut faire plein de choses
croisés c'est un outil qui est
extrêmement puissant c'est vachement
bien et puis ensuite lorsqu'il est
arrivé le coc vide en 2020 c'était
compliqué comme tout le monde je pense
en disant je vais moins pouvoir bosser
je vais moins pouvoir faire de vidéos
tous les jours pourquoi parce que j'ai
une compagne qui travaillent ouais et
que j'ai mon fils est que mon fils c'est
l'école du moins pendant le premier
conflit demande donc ça a été
extrêmement évident et j'ai dû baisser
le rythme de publication sama crée un
stress énorme mais j'ai fait des trucs
intéressants j'ai pu faire une team de
vidéos que je faisais pas avant donc ça
c'était pas mal donc j'ai baissé le
rythme est là je dirais que je me suis
retrouvé sur la période 2000 20 à 2021
où j'ai moins publiées mais je me suis
retrouvé dans un gros état de stress et
puis j'en avais je vous le dis
honnêtement ras le pompon de faire des
montages monter vous en dirons plus de
vidéos à monter tous les jours pendant
des années c'est épuisant donc j'ai eu
une année sur l'année 2020 2021 et ses
montées en puissance en 2021 et je peux
vous le dire parce que c'était très
compliqué j'étais je pense un peu à la
limite du burn out et ça en fait je m'en
étais déjà vendu coup parce qu'on avait
fait renaître gay youtube ça devait être
en 2019 on est fan ateliers autour du
bien-être youtube et youtube a dit
maintien qui sait qu'ils sont irritables
qu'ici kiss à qui ça et là que tu dis
mais en fait qu'ils sont en train
d'écrire c'est ce que j'ai tous les
jours là tu laves la menthue baisse la
tête et tu te dis ok j'en ai vraiment
pris conscience et c'est monté en
puissance en fait ça 2019 2020 2021 et
je me suis dit si tu veux plus possible
et je suis ami de péter les plombs par
moment donc je publié - j'étais en
retard enfin bref test et voilà c'est
une galère absolue et j'ai recherché un
monteur alors j'avais déjà le projet en
2020 puis avec le coach j'ai tout arrêté
et du coup j'ai cherché et au final j'ai
fini par trouver une boîte de prod qui
me fait mon tout mes montages où tous
les montages ont défoncé par une boîte
de prod et que je remercie kibo super
bien et d'ailleurs qu'aucun auteur et
donc ça me permet de reposer relâcher la
pression ça me permet de travailler
d'avoir un temps de travail qui va tout
autant géré je travaille toujours autant
je me suis accordé un truc que je me
connais pas c'est le fait pas travailler
le week-end donc je m'accorde le samedi
et le dimanche alors j'ai toujours faire
des choses je regarde toujours les
emails faut essayer de rattraper les
e-mails des fachos un peu de contacts
qui a l'amour des fois je remets un peu
mon planning en place mais je tourne
plus je monte plus et ça voilà ça me
libère mais vous imaginez même pas
comment donc la gestion du temps de
travail et ne pas venir sous-estimé
quand on est tout seul et qu'on veut
bosser afin qu on veut que ça marche le
fait qu'à un moment vous risquez de
péter les plombs et ça je vous le dis
c'est super important c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment important ou fait
vraiment gars faites attention à vous
écouter votre entourage quand il vous
dit wop pow pow pas les temps de mon
garçon voilà donc face lui faut vraiment
faire gaffe appuyez-vous sur des outils
et lorsqu'on a de la visibilité et qu'on
voit ce qu'on va faire déjà on est un
petit peu moins de charges sur les
épaules d'autant plus que moi dans mon
job est bien effectivement vous le voyez
à youtube mais qu'il ya pas que youtube
il va y avoir d'autres raisons que j'ai
envie de développer à savoir tik tok que
je trouve vachement cool et j'adore ces
petits formats courts alors tik tok ça
m'emmène sur instagram alors instagram
c'est surtout les riches ce qui
m'intéresse je vais développer du coup
du facebook watch que je trouve aussi
super intéressant mais ya pas que ça
parce que moi j'adorais j'ai commencé
par la radio quand j'étais plus jeune du
coup j'ai lancé un podcast et j'adore le
podcast mais comme je faisais de la
radio je faisais du direct et faisait
une libre antenne à l'époque eh ben je
me suis lancée sur twitter donc en fait
je me suis retrouvé à voir une activité
sur youtube où je bossais à fond comme
un dingue à avoir quand même
1198 vidéos en quelques années est bien
bien bas en fait je me soulage en entend
plus mais je m'en remet plein la tronche
n'ai je trouve ça cool donc ça me plaît
bien d'envoyer il ya toujours pas la
chose à faire donc c'est important c'est
de venir structurés ont bien
hiérarchiser les priorités on voit ce
qu'il faut faire il faut de la
visibilité et il faut que ça tienne dans
votre planning sans vous flinguer et ça
croyez moi c'est important donc à tous
cette organisation de temps de travail
qui est là ça me permet d'avancer en
ayant un monteur donc je continue
toujours à tourner énormément je tourne
de l'ordre de 5 à 6 vidéos par semaine
mais par contre je me suis dit vraiment
le week end je trompe pas je trouve plus
le week-end le week-end je pose donc
c'est tout là croyez-moi c'est vachement
important mais une fois dessus ça
correspond à moi ma force on bosse et je
suis un vrai boulimique dans le travail
j'adore tellement de choses j'ai
tellement envie de vous parler de sujets
que je suis toujours en train de
regarder et bien si on revient
décortiqué ma façon de bosser tous les
jours et bien tous les jours je dois
faire quoi je dois trouver des sujets je
dois les écrire je dois les tournées et
ça c'est que pour youtube et je fais la
même chose pour le reste alors le
podcast c'est une fois par semaine mais
sur tik tok il faut être extrêmement
régulier pour réfléchir à ça tous les
jours donc c'est se dit pas ça pour dire
que c'est ça qu'il faut faire je pense
pas que ça guérit faire correspondre à
moi vous ce qu'il vous faut c'est vous
dire ok je structure j'aime ma boîte ok
je monte
je le peux une société je m'entoure bien
si je peux j'ai les moyens je prends un
monteur pour me dégager du temps ça me
permet ensuite de créer des trucs des
projets annexes que j'ai envie de
développer parce que ça me plaît si ça
me plaît ça me plaît pas je ne fais pas
et puis je prends soin de moi et puis il
n'ya pas que youtube dans la vie y'a pas
que ça il ya la vie de famille et croyez
moi que la vie de famille des fois
l'empathie un peu pour ma part moi je
lui toujours beaucoup en déplacement
j'habite à clermont ferrand avec ma
famille je suis quasiment tout le temps
toute la semaine à 3 4 jours par semaine
à parler parce que le sait une chose se
passe ici et quand je suis pas à paris
mais je suis en déplacement là en début
d'année j'étais à las vegas pour le cs
l'achète à barcelone la semaine dernière
je repars à barcelone en trois semaines
ils se bougent leurs parts à new york
bientôt enfin dans la il ya plein de
salon est si génial il faut aussi être
clair lorsque vous avez une vie de
famille comment il faut que 5000 accepte
et voilà il faut prendre du temps pour
vous donc voilà je crois que je faisais
à peu près tout dit ouais tenir un
planning passé submergées et puis moi
j'ai la chance d'être accompagné par
youtube où j'ai effectivement le choix
des managers qui va m'aider me donner
des bons conseils pour voir un peu ce
qu'il faut faire et pas faire la même
chose sur assure type stock alors sur
instagram facebook et twitter c'est
absolument pas j'en ai pas d'ailleurs
certifié un compte pour éviter ne
serait-ce que la visibilité cognac et
jarnac vous n'arrivez jamais à les
joindre ces gens là donc voila moi je
vous dirais lorsque vous êtes débutant
ne prenez pas peur tout ce que je vous
ai montré là les choses se font petit à
petit ça se fait étape par étape mais
c'est bien d'avoir un peu cette vision
d'ensemble et de comprendre comment ça
se passe comment on avance sur youtube
comment on avance dans ces métiers là
quelle est la réalité parce que on voit
toujours beaucoup de choses qui nous
plaisent mais il ya une vraie réalité
que ce soit toutes les chaînes des
chaînes de divertissement si vous prenez
des gens comme max fayet carlito qui
cartonne et qui sont extraordinaires et
ben ils doivent aussi structuré des
choses ils ont aussi un des questions
avec des marques il le disait ce que
d'ailleurs très pas trop de sponsoring
avec ces lieux il ya toutes ces
questions là qui vient de se poser et
qui se pose pour tout le monde et tous
les créateurs lorsqu un moment vous avez
la chance de pouvoir vivre de votre
passion ça c'est génial et puis je
dirais qu'après il ya un autre truc
important c'est d'avoir un peu des
visions sur visibilité c'est eux
prochaine en l'avenir qu'est ce qui va
se passer quel va être l'avenir ces
plateformes est ce qu'un avenir sur
cette plateforme parce qu'on n'a pas la
main sur l'algorithme de youtube sur
canal gola et puis et puis prendre du
bon temps s'amuse et ne pas oublier que
tout ça c'est avant tout une passion
c'est avant tout du plaisir c'est avant
tout de faire les choses parce qu'on
aime les faire parce qu'on a envie de
les faire que rien ne vous y oblige et
que c'est pas parce qu'aujourd'hui bien
vous gagnez votre vie avec ça que ça
veut dire que demain rien continue et si
un jour sont la passion s'étiole bien
fait autre chose dans tous les cas ça
serait une super expérience dans tous
les cas vous vous serez armée et puis
vous aurez partager des moments
extraordinaires et moi c'est ce que
j'aime partager des moments
extraordinaires rencontrer de belles
personnes voire de nouveaux produits
offrent toujours un oeil un peu dans le
futur et puis voyage et j'adore ça voilà
donc j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
montré plein de choses une facette de
youtube qu'on ne voit jamais de youtube
des réseaux sociaux la vie de créateur
de contenu tout cas quelques mois de la
vie tels que moi je la conçois être
structuré être droit être éthique
partager s'amuser découvrir et puis
voilà quoi tout simplement donc j'espère
que ça vous aurait intéressé si vous
avez des questions pour les poser en
commentaire je répondrais je prendre un
peu de temps parce que je sais que c'est
pas toujours évident lorsqu'on débute
devez savoir comment prendre donc
comment prendre les choses donc poser
vos questions aux commentaires et puis
moi je prenais du temps à y répondre
voilà cette vidéo est longue mais je
pense qu'elle était importante pour
venir un peu des sacs réaliser des
choses pour nous montrer expliquer et
puis il ya si demain vous avez envie de
faire des vidéos sur youtube et que vous
avez envie de vivre de votre passion va
peut-être voilà un peu comment il faut
il faut il faut monter les choses tout
en sachant que je parle de moi de la
tête parce que c'est dans la tête il n'y
a pas deux domaines d'activités c'est
toujours un peu la même idée en tout cas
mais bon voilà voilà vous savez tout
allait pour des soins de nous embrasser
et surtout vive et de ma passion
amusez-vous il écourte qu'il faut
s'amuser un bisou de labour à m
[Musique]